[Musique]
voici le tueur présumé derrick may sont
photographiés au moment de son
arrestation
à ses côtés son complice présumé 20 ans
seulement persuadé que s'enfuir en
espagne leur permettrait d'échapper à la
justice par rapport aux policiers qui a
été tué mais du moment aucun artisan par
le mythique
il amène leur site ils vraiment c'est
dramatique
il est reparti puis j'ai revu à 21h il
est revenu pendant le repas c'est
incroyable comme il s'acharne sur lui
c'est vraiment il leur faut un coupable
c'est tout vous avez des au pouvoir
qu'il est la mesure qu'on mettait en
place pour éviter qu'un policier se
fassent abattre parce qu'il est policier
il appelle à la création tout de suite
d'une police nationale de proximité doté
de 30 mille hommes et femmes tué un
policier
c'est un acte de séparatisme et je veux
qu'il y ait une adéquation entre la
façon dont les terroristes doivent être
judiciairement traités et la façon dont
les auteurs d'homicide sur les policiers
doivent être traités
l'incarcération des deux suspects ne
fait désormais guère de doute preuves
accablantes
le tireur présumé a été formellement
reconnu par le collègues du policier
abattu la peine plancher faire en sorte
qu'on sent que tu as he is l'uniforme de
la république
c'est dire on touche pas l'uniforme si
tu touches uniforme le soir même tu dors
en prison pourquoi ça ne marche pas
parce qu'en réalité
constitutionnellement ça n'est pas une
vraie peine minimale les juges peuvent
toujours ne pas la prononcer cette peine
plancher
d'ailleurs seuls 37% des peines étaient
des peines planchers pour ses auteurs de
crimes contre les forces de l'ordre
jean castex promet spécifiquement une
peine de sûreté passant de 22 à 30 ans
des possibilités de réductions de peines
strictement limitées le problème c'est
que les peines de sûreté
à 30 ans il faut déjà qu'ils y ait une
condamnation à perpétuité
or vous savez très bien que les juges ne
condamne pas systématiquement ceux qui
blessent ou même tuer des policiers au
maximum des peines commandant éric
masson au nom du président de la
république et en vertu des pouvoirs qui
nous sont conférés
nous vous faisons chevalier de la légion
d'honneur
là on a un chef de l'état qui nous dit
ah mais moi ça m'intéresse pas du tout
la france j'aime pas la france j'aime
pas les français me connaissent à
l'envoi juste la police tabasser les
pauvres gilet jaune qui disent qu'ils
vont pas pouvoir payer leur plein
d'essence se passe sanitaire subordonne
l'accès des personnes à certains lieux
établissements ou événements impliquant
de grands rassemblements
on disait le général de gaulle qu'il
aimait la france mais pas les français
je pense que manuel main qu'on n'aime ni
la france ni les français
non seulement on n'est pas sûr de
l'efficacité mais en plus vous ouvrez
encore une fois tu votes l'andorre j'ai
dit à l'heure vous pouvez pas nous
garder à monsieur ministre qu'à part
seulement vous allez toucher à ça ça ne
se généralise pas parce que le réflexe
de tout le monde ça sera demandé à
l'entrée de n'importe quel lieu social
quand vous ouvrez au parisien
aujourd'hui tu l'as dit yann vous
découvrez un cadeau extraordinaire à le
calendrier des réouvertures à découper
qu'un doigt ses records à afficher dans
votre chambre pour découvrir qu'elle est
là georges d'occupation dans l'éboulis
au 9 juin
ou quel est le plafond du nombre de
personnes autorisées dans une salle des
fêtes le 19 mai mais le clou du
déconfinement c'est la réouverture des
remontées mécaniques dès le 19 mai
on n'a pas le droit de traverser la
frontière
je dois me tenir à un mètre de mon côté
et lui un maître aussi de son côté
en fait il faut qu'il y ait deux mètres
entre madame pour les boîtes de nuit
pour l'instant effectivement je ne suis
pas en mesure de nourrir vous voyez bien
pourquoi la boîte de nuit bien sûr bon
faire des tas pour moi qui vit seule
c'est très important de voir aulas sans
sage déprimerait nous sommes de vrais
jumeaux et on dit que les vrais jumeaux
et sont plus difficiles à séparer que
les jumeaux normes